DeSantis is the future of free America
and Trump has to figure out if he wants
to fit in that or not yes does Trump
have the power to burn the whole thing
down right now and Destroy DeSantis
probably could he figure out a way to do
it and just split the party and just
create endless chaos yeah I voted for
Trump the second time I've met him I've
liked him I I've interviewed him he's
got to figure this thing out now in a
decent way uh and I don't know if he has
it in him but you can feel it people are
people are starting to turn now you
don't think he has it in him to realize
that it's de Santa so you don't think he
has it in him to make another run you
don't think he has nothing in him to the
form be a unifier for the Republican
Party does he have it in him to be he
could be the king maker imagine if
instead of next week instead of what
everyone thinks is going to happen which
is that he announces that he's running
imagine if he gets up there and he says
you know I've looked at the lay of the
land I've been doing this for a long
time I'm of a certain age DeSantis he's
the guy he's the guy and let me help
what a great and not not even an ending
but what beautiful next chapter of the
Trump story I'll get out there I'll do
rallies I'll fight for the it's all
you're I can already see it
yeah but I mean that's a great that's a
great that's a hopeful Wishful thing but
as a New Yorker as somebody with his ego
I wish I wish I agree
but I love it but maybe we gotta maybe
we gotta pump the hell out of that story
so he hears it because if Trump is one
thing he does hear what people want you
know and if the story is man you can
still be loved you can be loved and
accomplish some of the things that you
wanted to accomplish but getting through
the machine again and that you're gonna
have to take out this I mean that the
sanctimonious line a couple days ago
yeah why who's sanctimonious did you
look up the definition of sanctimonious
I looked it up yeah and it's basically
like
okay and then I like Trump this is not
show the definition of what's saying
yeah it's kind of by the way because
when he comes up with crooked Hillary or
you know whacking crazy Nancy sleepy Joe
sleep it's not off the cuff yeah I mean
a lot of the stuff that he does is
certainly off the cup don't no doubt but
this is well thought out all right we're
going with sleepy Joe sanctimonious
making a show of being morally Superior
to other people so he's like I could say
anything I want about Ron to scam to
whatever name you want to go he's like I
want to call him you're not holier than
thou it's okay you're not chosen by God
buddy he picked that on purpose so in my
in my opinion give me one example one
example ever in Trump's life where he's
like I will take a back seat you be the
leader never I've never seen it no I
know but that's why the story right like
if he wants to do the hero's journey
here it's like man do it no I know I
know it's crazy I know it's crazy but
it's worth getting more people to talk
about it for the next two weeks because
otherwise he's going to announce and
they are gonna have to battle it out I
would say this DeSantis will be by far
if if he wants to run I don't know if he
wants to run I know him decently well
now
my show from the victory thing I mean
the guy he's surrounded by incredible
people he's competent he's decent he's
clearly a good husband he's a good
father it's like it's not going to get
better than this I don't worship
politicians I don't no it is not going
to get better than this guy and I would
say the real question for those of us
that live in uh in Florida and I really
honestly can't believe that you live in
California Ricky
um is do we want him to run you know I
think there's an argument to just keep
him here and let's keep this place as
strong as it can be and
you know I think I think that's worth
thinking about the opening the opening
where you have an opening to capitalize
he's
yeah he's never been better no I mean
okay so okay so 62 out of 67. what's he
gonna do better four years from now like
what's gonna be better than today you
know everybody won in your state you
flip the purple into red
are you gonna be able to Peak that it's
kind of like you know you're wanting to
get a contract with a team and you want
to sign a 10-year you know half a
billion dollar contract like you do you
are with baseball no I'm gonna I'm gonna
play one more you're on a one-year
contract and I'll renegotiate my no no
no no no go like this year right now
yeah Aaron judge judge it how many home
runs last year 62. yeah so he broke he
broke the record around now is the time
to renegotiate except your 10-year
contract he's probably gonna end up
going to the Giants based on what Tom is
saying but he he needs to now get his
half a billion Auto contract what do you
think what would you make of it if he
just was like I I don't want to do it
like I love this state I love what I'm
doing I love everything that I can
accomplish here and I think that the
machine is so easy if he said that yeah
I don't think he I don't think he's that
guy yeah I think he's a guy that is a
leader amongst leaders I think he's a
guy that has had his uh I set on leading
for a long time so he was a teenager I
don't think this I think this this guy
was a teenager you would have known
something was different about him I
think if he was 22 years old you're at a
bar having a drink with him and talking
to him his language you're gonna know
this is not a regular guy if you're
watching a football game with him you're
like this guy's gonna do something I
don't know what it's going to be and
he's done it you know being a commander
and being a commander of a Navy SEAL
unit to go on and being Congress six
districts Daytona to go being a governor
you would only buy 34 000 votes and then
it's Landslide 40 to 60 Charlie Chris
and then everybody in your State wins
because of you and then you flip a
purple to a red this is it so if he's
ever gonna run this is your opening if
he's not now here's the part if he does
if he does run
now my concern if I'm him is the
following because this is also what you
don't want it's the replacement game my
entire mindset would be if I'm him it's
who am I replacing because if you are
going to go be the president and if you
are a king maker who's the next person
that you're working or developing or
thinking to say here's a five or six or
seven candidates that would make a hell
of a governor in the State of Florida
let's start kind of shaping their
mindset of course some people gonna come
from the outside I think that's what I
would be thinking about if I'm him it's
probably on my top 10 list right now to
find my replacement if I run for
president if I'm not planning on running
for president ever
uh then you don't need to think about
that because you have plenty of time
they've got to be thinking about it one
way or another and again I have no
insight into I know his people pretty
well I have no insight into whether he
wants to do it or not but they have to
be thinking about that but I'll tell you
a great story about uh him and running
and how huge this victory was so when we
finished up my book tour the last stop
that we did was in Orlando and I had
DeSantis as my special guest so we went
right into Disney and and did this show
there and they had protesters and
they're screaming and all the usual
nonsense but I'm sitting in the green
room with the governor Just the Two of
Us for about 10 minutes before the show
and we're just mostly want to talk about
baseball actually we're just kind of
yeah like it wasn't about politics he's
just a decent dude and uh and I said to
him I said uh you know Governor you're
going to win this thing by 15 points he
laughed in my face he said six or seven
six or seven and now he won by 20. I
mean think about that he thought six or
seven he said six or seven and that
would be huge and the guy won by Twenty
so with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks Sprite if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people were in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bad toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
[Music]